welcome to this video playing pictures
pitch us which us from the US I guess
let's see solo phone reversed goon felt
a reversal thought I green felt without
deform but we can get down if he goes
default he's not queen bee three ads
very oddly Queen move now I wonder what
about c5 maybe maybe try and try to use
some pawn CM c 596 you may be okay does
he have maybe he has some some annoying
Quincy for something about play 95 ok I
need to do it anyway so let's get ahead
yeah 96 I guess hoping for Bishop e6
with the tempo later oh that looks very
weakening
because a five you should be six many
good squares for the Queen can also
start with C form but ok Bishop you six
looks looks better maybe you can play
Queen a three you can come down I was
thinking Bishop c5 would trap the queen
but this is not the case yes you can
take c5 and that is a very very
problematic
hmm that's not good not at all okay but
look at it okay if it does that I can
actually take a five that's not that bad
I have night be three I mean I have more
pieces and play so shouldn't be so
terrible he has moved the Queen a number
of times and the a pond well I was only
moving pieces okay um to be 3m I guess
brooke p8 just that or anything better
maybe just repeat
it gets it gets it gets my pieces into
plain Ruby eight also now in the game um
yeah a seven hang so do i need to cover
that on I wonder if I'm somehow maybe
I'm able to trap the Queen here it's not
looking that great moving the Queen all
the time but a seven hangs I don't don't
see it at the moment anything right so
okay let's just get this also in Queen a
seven rook or iced tea is doing this
Queen 87 look here Queen B seven items
cannot wrap the Queen am funny at least
I don't see it Bishop c4 now with the
temple but this is also not looking bad
them now let's do that come on attack
the rook we try to take on be to air on
C 1 and T 2 RB 2 a.m. this was this was
of course an option just take be to hear
on or exchange exchange Queens with
Queen B 6 I can take you seven maybe
okay
just grab this 95 looks a bit bit
awkward okay anyway to coordinate this I
can take here to play night a4tech on c3
editors in fact an idea that's it's not
so nice to give up the dark squared
bishop but it gets my pieces coordinated
the night on be tours offside okay 92
with the tempo when I can go Bishop c4
in fact or here and take that's maybe
easier check the check drug be one
trade-off trade-off pieces before he can
initiate some sort of counter play
against my king whether dark squared
bishop is missing
yeah time warning check check he and
queen to do one check check check
isn't there someone here with the Queen
comin around him he's got h6 yeah for
for the king attacking the knight 95
Queen f6 with Queen g7 made coming I
hope I what the hell does Queen f8 whoa
this is not good his King right right in
the middle of my position is a big
problem do I get the night in the game
somehow night to somewhere c3 or
that's it so really really tricky
maybe maybe H for something h4 g4
threatening to take this thing alright
still it's still winning though if he
does check I say f 6 seconds how ironic
can you be I have six seconds I'm never
going to win this because i cannot
checkmate them or insane how insane is
this check check Jack for Fitz on time
ya know it's wrong can you six just need
one more move to take off this bloody
porn I was sick how sick is this
sometimes he just walks the king all the
way to h6 and every move Windsor Queen
f2 everything wins check this is of
course also in at there it's not it's
not easy it's not easy with 40 seconds
queen is Queen here and now Queenie 7 is
in fact even a win unbelievable Queenie
6 would still win he didn't he didn't
find the window we form the IFOS is
tricky now here 26 and now g 5 wins of
course it does of course it does g5
because this is of course Nate really an
idea and here i can do this and it's
over with this that's even today that I
can yeah okay yeah well I saw that this
is of course losing from idea totally
losing but I have six seconds and with
six seconds I'm not going to win this ah
what a game I need a break thanks for
watching